I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事人才知道的独家幕后故事。
We're The Office, ladies. Good morning, lady. Oh, we have a really amazing guest on Office, ladies, today. We're the Office Ladies. Good morning, lady. Oh, we have a really amazing guest on Office Ladies today. We sure do. All of you that listened to the work bus last week know that today in the studio, we have Brian Cranston.
我们是《办公室》女士们。早上好，女士。哦，今天我们在《办公室女士》节目中迎来了一位非常棒的嘉宾。我们是《办公室女士》。早上好，女士。哦，今天我们在《办公室女士》节目中迎来了一位非常棒的嘉宾。我们确实如此。上周听过工作巴士那期节目的所有人都知道，今天我们在演播室迎来了布莱恩·克兰斯顿。
We cannot wait for you guys to hear this interview because, look, there are certain episodes of the office that are just real big episodes and they weren't extra time and work bus is definitely one of those. It's definitely one of those. Yeah and we shared all about our experience on that bus but we really felt like you needed to hear from the director as well so we reached out to Brian he was so kind and gracious he came into the studio and chatted all things work bus with us. And more. Now, I know a lot of people know Brian Cranston from his many acting roles.
我们迫不及待地想让你们听到这段采访，因为，听着，《办公室》里有些集数确实是非常重大的集数，它们需要额外的时间和努力，而工作巴士绝对就是其中之一。它绝对是其中之一。是的，我们分享了我们在那辆巴士上的所有经历，但我们真的觉得你们也需要听听导演的看法，所以我们联系了布莱恩，他非常善良和亲切，他来到演播室，和我们畅谈了关于工作巴士的一切。还有更多。现在，我知道很多人通过布莱恩·克兰斯顿的许多演艺角色了解他。
He's been in film and television and he's been on Broadway. You know, there's Malcolm in the middle and Walter White on Breaking Bad. And he even won a Tony Award for the Broadway play all the way. He's amazing, but Brain is also a very accomplished director. He directed episodes of Malcolm in the middle of Breaking Bad, Modern Family, Sneaky Pete, and his new series Your Honor on Showtime, and of course, this very epic famous episode of The Office. this very epic famous episode of The Office. And he is just delightful.
他出演过电影和电视，还演过百老汇。你知道的，有《马尔科姆的一家》以及《绝命毒师》里的沃尔特·怀特。他甚至还凭借百老汇话剧《一路到底》赢得了托尼奖。他太棒了，但布莱恩同时也是一位非常出色的导演。他执导过《马尔科姆的一家》、《绝命毒师》、《摩登家庭》、霓裳魅影，以及他在Showtime的新剧《法官大人》，当然，还有《办公室》这集极其史诗般著名的剧集。这集极其史诗般著名的《办公室》。而且他非常惹人喜爱。
He's so much fun to talk to. It was such a joy having him. And Jenna, you know what? I was thinking we didn't bring this up to him, but I want him to direct our road trip movie if we ever do it. Oh my gosh, yes! We've never even shared. Have we shared about the fact that me, you and Lee
和他聊天太有趣了。能邀请到他真是太高兴了。珍娜，你知道吗？我在想，我们没有跟他提起这件事，但如果我们要拍公路旅行电影的话，我想让他来执导。哦天哪，是的！我们甚至从来没有分享过。我们分享过我和你还有李……
have a road trip idea? We came up with an idea for a road trip movie. Lee wrote it. It's so funny. It's so funny. I know. Some of the hardest I have laughed in a long time was when the three of us were sitting at your dining table
有一个公路旅行的点子吗？我们想出了一个公路旅行电影的点子。李写的。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。我知道。我好久没有笑得这么厉害了，当时我们三个坐在你的餐桌旁……
and we were pitching jokes. Because listen, you guys, this is a road trip movie about two gals that are like in their 50s. But anyway, I mean, it has a mom detectives element to it, I have to say. It really does. Yeah. But would Brian Cranston ever direct anything
我们在抛出各种笑话。因为听好了，伙计们，这是一部关于两个大概50岁左右的女性的公路旅行电影。不过话说回来，我得说，它确实带有一点妈妈侦探的元素。真的有。是的。但是布莱恩·克兰斯顿会愿意在路上执导任何……
on the road again? That's the question. I think after you listen to this interview, you might find that he would be very hesitant to do so. Well, listen, the office might have ruined him forever in directing anything in a moving vehicle again, but let's let him tell you about it. We're going to take a break.
再次执导吗？这就是问题所在。我想听完这个采访后，你可能会发现他对此会非常犹豫。嗯，听着，《办公室》可能已经彻底毁了他再次在移动交通工具里执导任何东西的想法，但让我们让他自己告诉你吧。我们要休息一下。
And when we come back, our interview with Brian Cranston about work bus, which is also known as death bus. We'll be right back. It's such a great interview. We'll be right back. Yeah. Yeah. Well, who wrote your opening theme song? Creep Breton. Creep Breton. Did he really? Yes.
当我们回来时，将播出我们对布莱恩·克兰斯顿关于工作巴士（也被称为死亡巴士）的采访。我们马上回来。这是一次非常棒的采访。我们马上回来。是的。是的。对了，谁写的你们的开场主题曲？克里德·布拉顿。克里德·布拉顿。真的是他吗？是的。
You know, I just realized who Creep was. You just did. I just in the last few weeks. Grass roots, all of that. Yes, the grass roots. And I'm thinking, that can't be the same. It's the same guy. Yes.
你知道的，我刚刚意识到克里德是谁。你刚刚才意识到。我也就是在过去几周里。草根乐队，诸如此类的。是的，草根乐队。我在想，这不可能是同一个人吧。就是同一个人。是的。
Now, my question to you, my first question, thanks for coming on the show by the way, my first question to you would be, did the show ever do a backstage idea about what Creed's background was? Did someone ever go, that guy looks so familiar? And, you know, did you ever do anything like that? I don't remember.
现在，我给你的问题，我的第一个问题，顺便谢谢你来上节目，我的第一个问题是，剧组曾经做过关于克里德背景的幕后设定吗？有没有人曾说过，这家伙看起来好面熟？而且，你们做过类似的事情吗？我不记得了。
There were so many pitches. There were so many people who wanted to do a whole episode just on Creed and his life and wanted him to be outed as Creed Bratton, Creed Bratton, because he's the only person on the show who has his full name as his character name. Like Angela is Angela on the show, but on the show her last name is Martin.
有太多的提议了。有太多人想要专门拍一集关于克里德和他的生活，并希望他的真实身份被曝光为克里德·布拉顿，克里德·布拉顿，因为他是剧组中唯一一个用自己的全名作为角色名的人。就像安吉拉在剧里叫安吉拉，但在剧里她的姓氏是马丁。
But Creed Bratton, the character is also Creed Bratton, the man, but I don't think it was ever revealed. I will say though, of all the characters, we have a show Bible, sorry. I have to, you guys, Brian, Brian, Brian, his microphone this morning, something's up with it, and there is a bar in front of his
但是克里德·布拉顿这个角色同时也是克里德·布拉顿本人，但我认为这从来没有被揭晓过。不过我要说的是，在所有角色中，我们有一本剧集设定手册，抱歉。我不得不，你们知道，布莱恩，布莱恩，布莱恩，他今天早上的麦克风，出了点问题，他面前有一个栏杆……
face and so for me to talk to Brian he has to look around the bar. Angela, it's safer to have a bar in front of my face. It helps the restraining order issue that we have. There you go. That we have. Anyway, all the characters had a, we had a show Bible of all their back history and Creed's is the craziest. It's the most fun to read.
脸前面，所以为了跟我说话，布莱恩不得不绕过那个栏杆。安吉拉，我脸前面有个栏杆更安全。这有助于解决我们之间的限制令问题。给你。我们有的。不管怎样，所有的角色都有一个，我们有一本包含他们所有人背景历史的剧集设定手册，而克里德的是最疯狂的。读起来最有趣。
He has like a family in Canada. He lives under his desk half the time. He's, it's like all over the place. No way, why didn't I get a chance to read that? That would have been great. They didn't give you the show Bible? No, I didn't get it. No one said it was available.
他在加拿大有个家庭。他有一半的时间都住在办公桌底下。他，就像是到处都是。不会吧，为什么我没有机会读到那个？那太棒了。他们没有给你剧集设定手册吗？没有，我没拿到。没有人说它可用。
Been given that. Absolutely should have been given that. Would have changed work bus. I'm gonna quit. Yeah. Ret given that. Absolutely should have been given that. Would have changed work bus. I'm going to quit. Retroactive. Well, we always like to ask people when they come on, first question, how did you end up working on the office?
给过那个。绝对应该给过那个。那会改变工作巴士。我要辞职了。追溯性的。好吧，我们总是喜欢在人们来的时候问他们第一个问题，你是怎么最终参与到《办公室》的制作中的？
Oh. How'd you get this job directing work bus? Tracy Katsky is a friend of mine and she was working as a consultant with David in the last year you guys were on the air. Okay. Right? And I had just finished my season with Breaking Bad and that was 2012. Yep. I think it was 2012. And Tracy calls and says, we're looking for directors for this new season.
哦。你是怎么得到这份执导工作巴士的工作的？特雷西·卡茨基是我的朋友，在你呆在荧幕上的最后一年里，她一直在和大卫一起担任顾问。好吧。对吧？我刚拍完《绝命毒师》的那一季，那是2012年。没错。我想是2012年。然后特雷西打电话说，我们正在为这个新季度寻找导演。
Would you be interested in coming on board the office? And immediately the answer was gonna be, of course, no. But I love the show. It's such a legendary show that any chance to be a part of it in some small way. And she said, I know you've been directing Breaking Bads and you're out in the desert and it's hot and it's sticky. How would you like to come to,
你有兴趣加入《办公室》吗？我的第一反应当然是，不。但我喜欢这部节目。这是一部如此传奇的节目，任何能以某种微小的方式参与其中的机会。她说，我知道你一直在导演《绝命毒师》，你在沙漠里，天气又热又黏。你觉得来……
was it Burbank, North Hollywood, wherever we were? And we work inside. Yeah, low-officerity, air-conditioned. It's a short day, air-conditioned, easy,, indoors five days, bang, bang, bang. Boom, boom, boom. And I said, oh, it sounds fantastic. Let's do it. And she said, well, we have such and such slot open.
是伯班克，北好莱坞，还是我们在的某个地方？我们在室内工作。是的，低官方性，有空调。时间短，有空调，轻松，室内呆五天，砰，砰，砰。轰，轰，轰。我说，哦，听起来太棒了。我们干吧。她说，好吧，我们有这样一个档期空着。
And I looked at my calendar and I said, I'll take that slot. And I don't know, you probably described it on your show before, but the way it works in television for directors is by time. You have no idea when you sign onto a show what your episode is going to be by the time it gets to your time slot. So we had no idea and it just so happened that Work Bus came onto my lap. What did you think when you read this episode?
我看了看我的日历，我说，我要那个档期。我不知道，你可能以前在你们的节目里描述过，但电视导演的工作方式是按时间来的。当你签约一个节目时，你根本不知道等你到了你的档期时，你的剧集会是什么样的。所以我们根本不知道，刚好工作巴士落到了我的头上。当你读到这一集时，你是怎么想的？
Yeah. Well, the first I was excited to read it, read it right away and work bus, oh, I don't know, oh, they exterminate, was it exterminating? No, we were exterminating, it was 11 years ago, I think. There was this electrical issue, magnet electromagnetic things in the walls. And White was going to have to open up all the walls and redo the electrical.
是的。嗯，首先我很兴奋能读到它，马上就读了，工作巴士，哦，我不知道，哦，他们灭虫，是灭虫吗？不，我们在灭虫，那是11年前吧。墙里有一些电气问题，电磁场之类的东西。然后怀特不得不把所有的墙都砸开，重新做电路。
So the basic idea is that there could not be a work stoppage found to be the best method to continue working while this work on the actual location. The office was taking place. So everybody had to load onto the bus, desks were on there as we all know, and we had to just keep traveling. We're in the San Fernando Valley in August. It's so hot in August. It's so hot. I went to the call sheets. It was 100 degrees this week. It was like triple digits.
所以基本的想法是，在实际地点的施工期间，找不到比继续工作更好的方法来避免停工。办公室拍摄正在进行。所以每个人都必须上车，如我们所知，桌子就在上面，我们只能继续前行。我们在八月身处圣费尔南多谷。八月太热了。太热了。我去查了通告单。这周气温有100华氏度。简直达到了三位数。
It was very hot. So the first thing I did was curse my friend Tracy Katz. She was like, damn you as if they knew, you know? But it was a challenge. I think we shot in on the set for a day and a half or something like that. I think that's short. And then the rest of the time we were on a bus.
天气非常热。所以我做的第一件事就是咒骂我的朋友特雷西·卡茨。她当时就像是，该死的，就好像他们知道一样，你知道吗？但这确实是一个挑战。我想我们在片场拍了一天半左右的时间。我觉得这很短。然后剩下的时间我们都在一辆巴士上。
On that bus or in the park. And then we were out of baseball field. I know we were. Yep, right. We had that fold open. Yeah. I enjoyed it for the most part, but there was a. There were some tough moments.
在那辆巴士上或者在公园里。然后我们在一个棒球场外面。我知道我们有。没错，对。我们把那个折叠起来了。是的。我大部分时间都很享受，但也有……有一些艰难的时刻。
Well, I have to say, okay, you know that our cast has renamed this episode Death Bus. This has come to you, I know. And Jenna and I wrote a whole chapter in our book about it, The Office BFFs. We have a copy for you. We signed inside. It says, Brian, we owe you our lives. Thanks, Angela and Jenna. It is chapter 12 and dedicated a whole chapter to this episode. And we have fantastic photos of you, but we realized after our book came out, you were doing press.
好吧，我得说，好吧，你知道我们的演员把这一集重新命名为死亡巴士。这你也知道，我知道。珍娜和我在我们的书中写了一整章关于这的内容，《办公室好闺蜜》。我们有一本送给你。我们在里面签了名。上面写着，布莱恩，我们欠你一条命。谢谢，安吉拉和珍娜。这是第12章，专门为这一集写了一整章。我们有关于你的精彩照片，但我们发现在我们的书出版后，你正在做宣传。
We felt really bad because every single producer clearly wanted you to be asked about death bus. Jenna was like, oh no, Ange. We wrote about this and now everyone is asking him the same question on every talk show. Why did you try to kill the cast of the office? Why did I try to kill the cast? Was it a murder for hire?
我们觉得很不好意思，因为每个制片人都显然希望你被问到“死亡巴士”的事。珍娜当时说：“哦，不，安吉。我们写了这事，现在每个人都在每个访谈节目里问他同一个问题：‘你为什么试图杀死《办公室》的演员阵容？’我为什么要试图杀死演员阵容？这难道是买凶杀人吗？
No one's asked. It was a failed- I can't discuss all those details. There is a current investigation going on. On going, on going. And indictments will be handed down. I have every reason to believe you two are in the clear. I can't be positive on that. But I have every reason to believe you two are in the clear. I can't be positive on that.
没有人问过。这是一次失败的——我无法讨论所有这些细节。目前正在进行调查。正在进行中，正在进行中。起诉书将要下达。我有充分的理由相信你们两个是清白的。我对此不能百分之百确定。但我有充分的理由相信你们两个是清白的。我对此不能百分之百确定。
But I have set of circumstances. It was hot and tight. You talk about the set being contained. Well, we're on a bus and we didn't have a lot of room. And if I recall, nothing was actually nailed down. Everything was kind of shifting around. Desks were actually shifting and moving. And I'm looking at this going,
但我有一套具体情况。当时又热又挤。你说过片场空间是封闭的。好吧，我们在公交车上，而且空间非常有限。如果我没记错的话，没有什么东西是真正固定住的。所有东西都在某种程度上移位。办公桌实际上在移位和移动。我看着这一切，心想：
oh my God, I think people didn't realize this bus is actually on the road, on an open street and moving. Well, at first there was comedy in that, right? Like at first we're traveling down the road and like our little coffee cup is moving across the desert. Are we? Are we? Are we?
天哪，我想人们没有意识到这辆车实际上是在路上、在公开的街道上行驶。好吧，一开始这其中包含着喜剧效果，对吧？就像一开始我们沿着公路行驶，我们的小咖啡杯在整个沙漠般的场景中移动。是吗？是吗？是吗？
Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we?
是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？
Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we? Are we? That's funny. It's funny. But then there was a part of the script where I guess Dwight swerves and we all kind of slide and we all are like, ah. Yeah, he's trying to get us to the pie. Yeah, get to the pie. And I guess the AD yelled to the cast, we weren't really swerving.
是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？是吗？太搞笑了。太搞笑了。但剧本里有一部分，我猜德怀特猛打方向盘，我们全都滑倒了，然后我们都发出“啊”的叫声。是的，他正试图带我们去买派。是的，去拿派。我想副导演对演员们大喊，我们其实并没有真的在打方向盘。
So lean right and we got to ah and no one bought it. It didn't look good. And so then. they unloaded rain. Rain left and a stunt driver got on the bus. They removed us from the tow rig and now we are truly just a bus traveling down the road and with a stunt driver. We listed what all was in the bus.
所以向右倾斜，然后我们发出“啊”的叫声，但没有人买账。看起来一点都不好。于是他们让雷恩下车了。雷恩离开了，一个特技驾驶员上了公交车。他们把我们从牵引装置上解开，现在我们真的只是一辆由特技驾驶员驾驶在路上的公交车了。我们列出了公交车里的所有东西。
Like we went back and screen grabbed it. It was a full like Arrowhead water jug dispenser, a microwave, a coffee pot, lamps, rolling chairs, desk, computers, a printer. Was there a little mini Xerox machine? I bet there was. So it was a full office. And it all, when the stunt driver swerved right, it all, it all swerved. Everything moved. And all of a sudden that was not part of the production
就像我们回去截屏确认的一样。里面有一个完整的箭头发明水机、一个微波炉、一个咖啡壶、台灯、转椅、书桌、电脑、一台打印机。里面是不是还有一个迷你的施乐复印机？我敢说肯定有。所以这是一个完整的办公室。而且当特技驾驶员向右猛打方向盘时，所有的东西都跟着晃动了。所有东西都在移动。突然之间，这根本不是我们制作讨论的一部分，顺便说一句。
discussion that we had, by the way. It was like, we're doing this, Rain's going to drive and we're going to do this. And it's all contained and we'll have the, the cast move back and forth. It didn't look good. Not everybody was in sync. And there was something funny about things happening at the same time and once and you can't duplicate that. You can't fake that. And so there was an idea and I don't believe it was my idea, but I'm not saying it's not
当时的想法是：我们要这么拍，雷恩来开车，然后我们照做。这一切都是封闭的，我们会让演员们前后移动。但效果不好。不是每个人都合拍。有些事情同时发生、瞬间发生时有一种奇妙的感觉，你是无法复制的。你无法伪造那种效果。所以大家产生了一个想法——我不认为是我的主意，但我不是说这不是……
to actually heighten the movement of the thing with a professional stunt driver. Yes, it was a professional stunt driver. It wasn't Rainn Wilson. We, however, are not professional stunt people. This is true. And this is where the beginning of the indictments will start. Yes.
而是用专业特技驾驶员来真正增强那种晃动的效果。是的，那是一个专业的特技驾驶员。那不是雷恩·威尔逊。然而，我们并不是专业的特技演员。千真万确。而起诉书也就是从这里开始的。没错。
And that's that. And the reality of it in retrospect, you look back and you go, oh my God, what were we doing? Oh, and then- Oh, wait, wait, wait. We don't wanna get to that part yet. Wait, I have to ask, you're not on the bus with us at this point.
事情就是这样。现在回想起来，现实情况是，你回头一看会想：“天哪，我们当时在干什么？”哦，还有——哦，等等，等等，等等。我们还不想讲到那个部分。等等，我得问一下，这个时候你并不和我们同在车上。
You're in like a follow van and you're watching this footage on a screen. What? Hang on, I was in the bus the entire time. Wait, you were in the bus? Yeah, yeah. For that moment? I was in the very back. And the way back on the back row. I was down on Yeah. For that moment? I was in the very back.
你坐在一辆随行的面包车里，在屏幕上看着这些画面。什么？等一下，我全程都在公交车里。等等，你在车上？对，对。就在那个时候？我就在最后面。最后一排的最边缘。我当时趴在……对，就在那个时候？我就在最后面。
And the way back on the back row. I was down on the floor. I remember that. I was on the floor with a little viewfinder and watching the thing as I'm moving back and forth too. I remember that. I knew you were on the bus most of the time, but I thought there were a few shots where it was like we had to clear everybody.
最后一排的最边缘。我当时趴在地板上。我记得。我拿着一个小取景器趴在地板上，一边移动一边看着那个画面。我记得。我知道你大部分时间都在车上，但我以为有几个镜头我们需要清场所有人。
We cleared boom. we had just camera. And I did not know that you still stayed on. I stayed on when it was, when there was room, when we were shooting, when I was able to hide in the back on the ground, when there was no room and shooting in one direction, I think I was off the bus. Because it was too dangerous and I said, I shouldn't be here.
我们清空了吊杆。我们只有摄像机。我不知道你居然还留在那。有空间的时候、我们在拍摄的时候、当我能够躲在后面的地上时，我就留下了；而当没有空间且需要朝一个方向拍摄时，我想我下了车。因为太危险了，我说，我不应该呆在这。
I'm catch-up-ing. I shouldn't be here. We did skip over one. So Jen and I, we were like trying to remember everything about this episode and filming it. And we were like, wait, we all had to get off the bus three times. The first one was because we got so tickled in Ellie Peter pants.
我得补上漏掉的。所以珍娜和我，我们当时在努力回忆关于这一集和拍摄的一切。我们觉得，等等，我们大家都不得不下车三次。第一次是因为艾莉笑尿了裤子。
Yep, remember? And we had to change her clothes. And she had it. And she had it. Oh, no, Ellie, don't worry. It's in the book. It's in the book. Ellie is such a good sport. Ellie was like, guys, and we had to change her clothes. And she had it. She had actually. Oh, no, Ellie, don't worry. It's in the book. It's in the book. Ellie is such a good sport.
没错，还记得吗？我们不得不给她换衣服。而且她真的弄湿了。而且她真的弄湿了。哦，不，艾莉，别担心。书里写了。书里写了。艾莉真是个很好的运动健将。艾莉当时说：“伙计们……”然后我们不得不给她换衣服。而且她真的弄湿了。她其实真的……哦，不，艾莉，别担心。书里写了。书里写了。艾莉真是个很好的运动健将。
Ellie was like, guys, I paid my skirt. And we all laughed. And it wasn't a huge pee. It was just a little. She actually did. Yeah. So, so then. Oh, whoops.
艾莉当时说：“伙计们，我把裙子尿湿了。”我们都笑了。那不是一笔大尿。只是一点点。她其实真的这么做了。是的。所以，所以接下来。哦，哎呀。
It wasn't just a saying. So we all pulled over. We hung out in the park. Ellie changed clothes. Then we all get back on the bus. And I remember Jenna, like us being like, this is crazy, what a crazy day. Thinking like, that's the craziest thing that'll happen.
这可不是随口说说。于是我们都把车停在路边。我们在公园里闲逛。艾莉换了衣服。然后我们又都上了车。我记得珍娜，就像我们当时说的那样：“这太疯狂了，这是多么疯狂的一天。”以为这已经是会发生的里最疯狂的事了。
Then the swerve and everything flew. I remember digging Creed out of a pile of things. Do you remember that Creed was totally covered? It was dangerous. I look back on it now and it was, I would like to think that that wouldn't happen today. It would all be zip-tied or... Yes, something. Here's the thing, our show did not travel well. We were very good at shooting inside of an office,
接着就是猛打方向盘，所有的东西都飞了起来。我还记得把克里德从一堆杂物里挖出来。你还记得克里德完全被盖住了吗？太危险了。现在回想起来，我真希望这种事在今天不会发生。所有东西都会被扎带固定住，或者……是的，有些措施。问题是，我们的剧不适合外景拍摄。我们很擅长在办公室内部进行拍摄，
but pretty much any time we left to go on the road, even just metaphorically, something happened. Yeah, we lost half the cast at sea. Yeah, that episode when you're on the booze cruise. We, Phyllis, Brian, and Rain drifted out to sea for about 20 minutes. On a dinghy. That's like 4.30 in the morning. 4.30 in the morning. Yes, because we were shooting nights.
但基本上只要我们离开去路上，哪怕只是在隐喻意义上，总会出事。是的，我们在海上失去了半个剧组。没错，就是你们在酒水游轮上的那一集。我们——菲利斯、布莱恩和雷恩在海上漂流了大约20分钟。
And you had the choice. You know, we were wrapped. They were doing the scene with Jim and Pam. They're like, do you want to stay on the boat till we wrap, or do you want to leave? And only this small group raised their hands, because we had to kind of climb down a ladder, hop on a dinghy.
坐在一艘小艇上。大约是清晨4点半。清晨4点半。是的，因为我们在拍夜戏。
To get back to shore. And then the engine broke down. And then the engine broke and they lost them. And we floated. For a while. Let's take a moment and think about them for just a second. They were such great cast members. And the famous thing is that everyone was like,
你当时有得选。你知道的，我们收工了。他们在拍吉姆和帕姆的戏。他们问：“你们想留在船上直到我们收工，还是想离开？”只有这一小部分人举手了，因为我们得爬下梯子，跳上小艇。
we lost Phyllis and me and Brian and Rain were like, Ann, Ann, Ann, hello. People only cared about Phyllis. I know, I know. Sweet Phyllis. Sweet Phyllis. Well, it's true that whenever we left set, things happened. So we're sorry.
我们丢了菲利斯，我和布赖恩还有雷恩就像是在喊：安，安，安，你好。大家只关心菲利斯。我知道，我知道。可爱的菲利斯。可爱的菲利斯。好吧，确实只要我们离开片场，就会发生状况。所以我们很抱歉。
It was hard. Well, okay, so there was a second thing that happened then. We, we un-piled ourselves. There was, then we, we were hot. And I remember being so excited after lunch. Didn't you guys have to turn the air off when we were filming? Cause it was loud.
这太难了。好吧，好吧，所以当时还发生了第二件事。我们，我们把自己从叠罗汉的状态中解脱出来。然后，然后我们热坏了。我记得午饭后我兴奋极了。拍戏时你们难道不用把空调关掉吗？因为声音太大了。
The AC in the bus was loud. Yes. It was loud. So there was this announcement, guys, we have a great thing. We have a portable AC unit that we're gonna pull on a trailer behind the bus. And we have a hose that is gonna go up through
大巴上的空调声音太大了。是的。声音很大。所以当时有这样一个公告：伙计们，我们有个好东西。我们有一个便携式空调机组，我们要用一辆拖车把它拉在大巴后面。我们有一根软管要通往
like this sunroof thing in the bus. And it'll be quiet. We can leave it on while we're filming. You guys aren't gonna be hot anymore. And we couldn't believe our look. We were so excited. This is fresh, wonderful, cool air. People were getting willty.
大巴上类似天窗的地方。这样它就很安静了。我们拍戏时可以一直开着它。你们大家就不会觉得热了。我们简直不敢相信自己的运气。我们太兴奋了。这是清新、美妙、凉爽的空气。人们都要热得枯萎了。
They were getting, so we were like in a hot tin can. It was really tough. And San Fernando Valley, like you said, it was 100 degrees. And then we made it worse by having the closed up windows and everything else to where the heat inside that bus. Oh God. I would think would be 110, 115. It was like a little sauna rolling down the road.
他们热得不行，所以我们就像是在一个热气腾腾的铁罐头里。真的很难熬。正如你所说，圣费尔南多谷的气温高达100华氏度。然后我们把窗户关得严严实实，再加上其他种种措施，让大巴内部的热度变得更糟。天哪。我估计得有110度、115度。就像一辆在路上行驶的小桑拿房。
And we were trying in the morning every time we cut, they tried to pump the air, but then we'd have to turn it off and you'd only be able to work for about five, 10 minutes before it became unbearable. So we got the little rolly unit. A brilliant idea. So wonderful.
而且我们每天早上都在尝试，每次导演喊停，他们就试图打空调，但接着我们又得把它关掉，你只能工作大约五分钟到十分钟，然后就热得让人无法忍受了。所以我们弄了那个小型滚动空调。真是个绝妙的主意。太棒了。
But then we started moving and my chair was right under the little sunroof. I was very excited. I was like, this is awesome. You're going to get all the air. Because I'm going to get the first amazing cool air. Yes. But I-
但接着我们开始移动了，我的椅子正好在那个小天窗下面。我当时非常兴奋。我想：这太棒了。你能吹到所有的风。因为我要吹到第一口神奇的凉风了。是的。但我——
And you did. I sure did. And I was- That part is true. It was very cool. I was smelling the air as it was cooling me and I was like, it doesn't smell right. It smells gassy.
你也确实吹到了。我当然吹到了。而且我——这部分是真的。非常凉爽。我闻着吹拂着我的凉风，心想：这味道不对劲。有一股汽油味。
It smells not right. And so you started voicing that. Yeah. And I was more towards the front and I was like, I don't smell anything. I don't, I don't, and there was a little bit of like, Jenna, a little bit. I know to be fair, I was the person on the set who had all the allergies
闻起来不对劲。然后你就开始把这事说出来了。是的。我坐得比较靠前，当时我想：我什么都没闻到。我没有，我没有。然后有点像——珍娜，有点像。我承认，公平地说，我是片场那个有过敏体质的人，
and I was ruining takes from sneezing all the time. And I think people thought it was just Jenna's allergy nose, Jenna sensitive. And I was like, no, no, no, it's not that. It's like gas. And then Sarah, our camera operator who was standing back there by you, she was like, I like wasn't-
我老是因为打喷嚏而毁掉镜头。我想大家当时都觉得那是珍娜过敏的鼻子，珍娜比较敏感。而我想说：不，不，不，不是那样的。这就像是汽油味。然后我们的摄像师莎拉，她当时就站在你身后，她有点——
She got a little loosey. Yeah. And then Brian, I think you came up and you were like, let me see what you're talking about. What wait, I stood on a chair right where your desk was and I put my face right up to the register where the air was coming. And sure enough, carbon dioxide. cold. I remember you go, get off the bus. That's what I'm saying. We all exited the bus and that is when you can tell everyone what they discovered that happened. Well, it was a great, great idea, but the execution was not thoroughly thought through.
她有点神志不清了。是的。然后布赖恩，我想你走过来，你说：让我看看你在说什么。等等，我站到了你桌子旁边的椅子上，把脸直接凑到了出风口那里。果不其然，一氧化碳。冷的。我记得你说：快下车。这就是我要说的。我们都下了车，也就是在那时，你可以告诉大家他们发现了什么。好吧，这是一个非常非常好的主意，但执行时并没有经过深思熟虑。
So what we came up with when we were realizing production meaning was that it's gonna be hot as hell on this bus, how are we gonna keep everybody from wilting? And I said, we can pull a portable air conditioning unit that is strong enough to pump fresh air into the bus. And my concern was I wanna be able to shoot toward the back so I can't see it. And we can make it low enough, small enough
所以在制作会议上我们得出的方案是：这辆车里会热得像地狱一样，我们怎么才能防止每个人都热得枯萎呢？我说：我们可以拖一个便携式空调机组，它的功率足以向大巴里泵入新鲜空气。我当时的顾虑是：我想朝着后面拍摄，这样我就看不见它。我们可以把它做得很低、很小，
to where it won't be seen throughout the windows. And we thought about we'd have to adjust the rear view mirrors just and what about the noise? And no, no, these new ones are, so we really thought about this. Okay, great, great, great. And we'll just tow it. We'll have a tow hitch on the bus.
从小窗户里根本看不见它。我们还考虑过必须调整后视镜，还有噪音怎么办？不，不，这些新型号的……所以我们真的考虑得很周全。好吧，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了。我们直接拖着它就行。大巴上会有个拖车钩，
We'll hook it up and we'll just tow this unit. It has its own generator. It's quiet and perfect solution. What could go wrong? Well, what went wrong was the intake for the air conditioning unit was positioned the way it's manufactured. And it's just so happens the way it was placed on this trailer was it was facing the back of the bus at about a foot and a half away from where this intake is is the exhaust pipe of the bus.
我们把它连上，然后拖着这个机组。它有自己的发电机。既安静又完美的解决方案。能出什么差错呢？嗯，出差错的地方在于空调机组的进气口是按照它出厂时的结构定位的。而很巧的是，它被放置在这辆拖车上的方式是：它正对着大巴的尾部，距离这个进气口大约只有一英尺半的地方，就是大巴的排气管。
So the fumes and exhaust from the bus only had about a foot distance away from the intake from the air conditioning. Just getting sucked up going right into the bus. There was no possibility of avoiding this. And it was locked down, but we didn't realize that until we were actually underway. And the thing was fired up.
所以大巴的废气和尾气距离空调的进气口只有大约一英尺的距离。直接被吸进去，又直接吹进了大巴里。根本没有办法避开这一点。而且它是锁定的，但直到我们真正开动起来并且启动了这台机器时，我们才意识到这一点。
And actually, Jenna, you and your sensitive nose saved our lives. Finally, it did some good in my life. You saved our lives. At first, how can exhaust becoming inside? It just doesn't make any sense to me. And sure enough, when I said I went, oh my god, we have made a huge mistake and we nearly killed the entire cast of the office. Really incredible. But I would say had no one detected it, what a beautiful way to go. All together. Right, oh my god, all together. Rolling down the road. Kumbaya. Shibuya roll call.
事实上，珍娜，你凭着敏感的鼻子救了我们的命。我的生活终于做了一件有益的事。你救了我们的命。起初，怎么会有尾气进来呢？这在我的逻辑里根本说不通。果不其然，当我开口时，我说：天哪，我们犯了个大错，我们差点害死了《办公室》的全体演员。真的太不可思议了。不过我想说，如果当时没有人发现，这也是一种美妙的离开方式。大家一起。对啊，天哪，大家一起。在路上行驶着。齐心协力。涩谷点名。
The big roll call. That's it. Ugh. Well, Leslie, I remember looking at Leslie David Baker and his eyes were bloodshot and watering. And I kept thinking like maybe the vent is hitting him at an angle. You know how it dries out your eyes?
盛大的点名。就是这样。呃。好吧，莱斯利，我记得我看着莱斯利·大卫·贝克，他的眼睛布满血丝而且在流泪。我一直以为可能是风口正对着他，角度不对。你知道风口是怎么把眼睛吹干的吗？
Like if a vent hits you, but no, it was just poison. Now was Leslie's desk close to yours? Yes. I'm trying to remember. But no, it was just poison. Now was Leslie's desk close to yours? Yes, when we had the, when we all went flying into one another, I believe I flew into Leslie. Did Leslie, when we got off, I remember he was like, I'm not getting back on. Leslie said I'm never getting back on the bus again. I'm done.
就像风吹到你一样，不，那纯粹是毒气。当时莱斯利的桌子离你很近吗？是的。我正努力回想。不，那纯粹是毒气。当时莱斯利的桌子离你很近吗？是的，当我们经历那场混乱、大家都朝彼此飞扑过去的时候，我记得我是朝莱斯利扑过去的。莱斯利在下车时，我记得他说：我再也不上车了。莱斯利说我再也不上大巴了。我受够了。
I'm done getting on the bus. I remember him walking to his car and driving away, but I think that might not be true. But for some reason, I remember Leslie was like, goodbye. I'm out. I'm out. Shoot around me. But also poor Leslie, whenever we went on locations, he got the worst of it. When we went to the beach, I got sand kicked in his eye and it scratched his cornea and he had to wear like a patch for a week. Yeah. Oh. So I think Leslie was like, I don't do scenes outside of the office. Yeah. Forget it.
我再也不上车了。我记得他走向自己的汽车然后开车走了，不过这可能不是真的。但不知为什么，我记得莱斯利当时的态度是：再见。我退出了。我退出了。在我周围拍吧。不过真可怜啊莱斯利，每当我们去外景地时，他总是遭遇最惨的。当我们去海滩时，有沙子飞进他眼睛里，刮伤了他的角膜，他不得不戴了一周的眼罩。啊。所以我觉得莱斯利当时的想法是：我才不在办公室外面拍戏呢。对啊。算了吧。
Forget it. I don't go on location. Yeah, shit goes down. It almost sounds like his character. You just drill, I don't go outside. Yeah, exactly. Don't leave the office. Were there any moments that you haven't talked about about this episode? Because we know you've been hit up with those questions quite a bit.
算了吧。我才不去外景地。这简直太糟了。这听起来有点像他在剧里的角色。你只要坚持：我不去户外。对，没错。别离开办公室。关于这一集，有没有什么你们还没聊过的事情？因为我们知道你们已经被问过好多次这些问题了。
But any behind the scenes memories that you have that you'd want to share? Yeah, those things are so on the frontal lobe that it's hard to remember. I just had a really good time other than worrying about that. I was really happy to be able to be on your set and see it and feel it. You guys, by the time I came along, it was the ninth season, so you were a well-oiled machine. The role of a guest director is not to come in and I wouldn't dare. Wouldn't dare say anything to an actor about their character. How wouldn't that be obnoxious?
不过你们还有什么想要分享的幕后记忆吗？对啊，那些事情在脑海里太深刻了，反而很难记清。除了担心那件事之外，我真的度过了一段美好的时光。我真的很高兴能来到你们的片场，看到它并感受它。伙计们，等我加入的时候已经是第九季了，所以你们已经是一个运转良好的机器了。客串导演的角色不是来指手画脚的，我也不敢。我才不敢对一个演员的角色评头论足呢。那样不是很令人讨厌吗？
Like season nine. I think you could make a different choice for white. I think let's make this, I think he's friendlier. Yeah. Why is he usually such a bitch? Yeah. What's with the cats? Let's do away with that.
就像到了第九季。我觉得你可以为德怀特做出不同的选择。我觉得我们来这样——我觉得他应该更友好一点。对啊。为什么他平时总是那么讨人嫌？对啊。这些猫是怎么回事？我们把这个去掉吧。
Forget all that. No more cats. No more cats. Yeah. And then you two, you know, I'd say I'd pull you apart. Yeah. Start to think about something about Jim that you didn't like. Yeah.
把那些全忘了。再也没有猫了。没有猫了。对啊。然后你们两个，你知道的，我会说我要把你们分开。对啊。开始去想一些关于吉姆你不太喜欢的地方。对啊。
Just throw a wrench into everything. He's like, I don't think this. So there's nothing. A director on episodic television just comes in and tries to, what my whole goal was, whenever I direct television, which is different from directing features because in features, you are trying and need to please yourself and make sure that you get
简直是要把整个局面搅得天翻地覆。他就像是在说：我不这么认为。所以什么都没有。电视情景剧的导演来这里只是想——我全部的目标是，每当我执导电视剧时（这和执导电影不同，因为在电影中，你尝试并且需要取悦自己，并确保你得到了
all those elements and moments that you've worked so hard in breaking down that script. In television, it's about staying true to these characters, putting them in positions where they can really be themselves, where they feel comfortable. It's delivering the meat and potatoes that every showrunner is going to expect from you. I always thought if I can deliver two or three things that the showrunner didn't see, that's golden. Just a couple little things. I think there's a few.
那些你在拆解剧本时付出无数心血才呈现出来的元素和时刻），在电视剧里，关键在于忠于这些角色，把他们放在能真正做自己的位置上，让他们感到舒适。这是交付每一个剧集统筹都对你抱有期待的核心内容。我一直认为，如果我能呈现出两三个剧集统筹没料到的东西，那就太棒了。只需要几个小细节。我想确实有那么几个。
When I rewatched the episode, I completely forgot that Ed placed the banjo at the end. Oh yeah, yeah. I mean, and just rips it. It's just so great. And everyone is just like, oh, whatever. Well, no, and it's true. I taught him the banjo in two weeks. And he was able to pick it up and perform that.
当我重温这一集时，我完全忘了埃德在结尾处弹了班卓琴。哦对，对，对。我是说，而且弹得太绝了。简直太棒了。然后每个人都觉得：哦，随便吧。好吧，不，真的。我用两周时间教他弹班卓琴。他竟然能学会并把它表演出来。
That's amazing. I loved all the pie scenes too. I thought they were really sweet. Did you eat any pie? I had some pie. Do you remember your flavor of pie? That's probably hard to remember. I'm thinking gooseberry.
太惊人了。我也喜欢所有的派的场景。我觉得它们真的很温馨。你吃派了吗？我吃了一点派。你还记得你吃的是什么口味的派吗？这可能很难记起来。我猜是醋栗派。
Yeah, yeah, that was, look how happy you were. Well, he remembered that. Wasn't that fun? Yeah. Because it's such a funny name, I like it. Yeah, there was like a, it was like a, I think it was gooseberry, because it wasn such a funny name. I like it. Yeah, there was like a, it was like a, I think it was gooseberry because it wasn't blackberry. No.
对，对，那就是——看你当时多开心。好吧，他还记得这个。那不是很有趣吗？对啊。因为名字太搞笑了，我很喜欢。对啊，好像有个——就像是个，我觉得是醋栗派，因为名字太搞笑了，我很喜欢。对啊，就像是个，好像是个，我觉得是醋栗派，因为它不是黑莓派。不是。
Yeah, but there was a special berry crumble pie. Pie. When I rewatched it, I just remember how happy we actually all were to sit outside and have pie. I had chocolate cream. It was delicious. Interesting choice on a very hot day.
对，但那是一种特别的莓果酥皮派。派。当我重温这一集时，我只记得我们大家坐在外面吃派时实际上有多么开心。我吃的是巧克力奶油派。太美味了。在大热天里做出了一个有趣的抉择。
What? Chocolate cream. What? Chocolate cream. What? Peel back the layers. Okay, I have got to do something. I have been going through the call sheets and on the back of the call sheet they do a thing called Get to Know your cast and crew. And they ask a few questions, but they're so interesting.
什么？巧克力奶油。什么？巧克力奶油。什么？剥开层层外壳。好吧，我得做点事情。我一直在翻看通告单，在通告单的背面他们有一个叫做“了解你的演职人员”的栏目。他们会问几个问题，但都非常有意思。
You mean on every one of your call sheets, it was get to know your cast and crew? Someone was featured on each call sheet. We had talked about, Jen and I wanted to start with each new guest, ask them a few of these questions. What was one of the first jobs you had in entertainment? One of the first jobs I had in entertainment, I think it was a soap opera.
你是说在你们每一份通告单上，都有“了解你的演职人员”这个栏目吗？每张通告单上都会特色介绍一个人。我们之前聊过，珍娜和我想在采访每个新嘉宾时，问他们其中几个问题。你在娱乐界的第一份工作是什么？我在娱乐界的第一份工作，我想是一部肥皂剧。
I was, I did like a three day role on Days of Our Lives. I love Days of Our Lives. Back in 1981. What was your character? I was a cousin of the person. I will tell you this. Bill and Susan Seaforth, he and his wife, Susan and Bill, they were on Days of Our Lives for years.
我，我在《我们的日子》里演了一个为期三天的角色。我超爱《我们的日子》。早在1981年。你演的是什么角色？我是那个人的表亲。我跟你讲这个。比尔和苏珊·西福思，他和他的妻子，苏珊和比尔，他们在《我们的日子》里演了很多年。
I happened to oversleep that morning, the first day that I was to work. And I missed the rehearsal, missed the blocking, missed everything. I'm panicking, absolutely panicking. And I race to NBC where we're shooting it. And I'm panicking, I'm nervous. And all of a sudden, I hear knocking on my dressing room door, and it's Bill Hayes, the big star of the show.
那天早上我碰巧睡过头了，那是我要工作的头一天。我错过了排练，错过了走位，错过了所有事情。我恐慌极了，绝对是惊慌失措。我狂奔到我们拍摄的NBC大楼。我慌乱又紧张。突然间，我听到有人敲我化妆间的门，是比尔·海斯，剧里的大明星。
And he says, I understand you had a problem this morning. We stood in for you and we blocked him. And he says, can I run down what we did? And do you need some help on the back story of the character? I was so appreciative. I was just a day player. And he put himself out there to say, look. That is so kind.
他说：我听说你今天早上遇到麻烦了。我们替你顶上并完成了走位。他说：需要我把我们做过的事给你过一遍吗？你需要了解一些关于这个角色的背景故事吗？我当时太感激了。我只是个只演一天的特约演员。他竟然主动走过来对我说：听着。这太暖心了。
Yeah, he was a lovely, lovely guy. And he helped me get over the anxiety of being late and the responsibility of that. And I spent all the money that I made on that episode to buy flowers for the people that I knew stood up for me and Bill and the casting director. And it was like, I'm so sorry. But that was my first experience.
对，他是个非常非常好的人。他帮我克服了迟到的焦虑以及由此产生的责任感。我把在那一集里赚到的所有钱都用来买花，送给那些我知道为我挺身而出的人、比尔还有选角导演。当时的感觉就像是：真的非常抱歉。但那是我的初体验。
Okay, I love that. I love that story. I love the kindness you were shown. I didn't know where that was going when you said he knocked on the door. I was like, oh no. Yeah, no. In a good way.
好吧，我太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢这个故事了。我喜欢你所感受到的这种善意。当你刚说他敲门的时候，我还不知道事情会发展到哪里。我当时想：哦不。是的，没那回事。是往好的方向发展。
In a good way. Okay, favorite place in the whole wide world that you've ever been to? I guess it would be Venice. I was there on my honeymoon almost 35 years ago. Very romantic and very unique. And we just had, there was one night when my wife and I were, there was a thunderous rainstorm. And we went to a Vivaldi concert in a church that had windows at the top of this sphere and this dome. It felt like God was adding the exclamation to it.
朝着好的方向。好吧，你去过的整个广阔世界里最喜欢的地方是哪里？我猜应该是威尼斯吧。我大约35年前在那里度蜜月。非常浪漫，非常独特。我们当时经历过，有一天晚上我和我妻子正赶上一场雷雨。我们去一座教堂里听了一场维瓦尔第的音乐会，那座教堂的球顶和穹顶上方有窗户。感觉就像上帝在为这一切加上叹号。
You know, oh my god, it was just so it was just so magical and romantic Unbelievable time. Wow. Have you been back since your honeymoon? Actually, no, it's been a long time We've been there twice and that was we haven't been back in 34 years. It's time to go back. I think it's time Yeah, I don't know. I I say don't mess with it time. I don't know. I say don't mess with it. What? I say leave it. Don't revisit? Never revisit a memory? Well, it's too good. It's too good. You know what I mean? If you go back and then you're gonna be like, oh my gosh, it smells and it's... What? I mean, no offense, Venice, but I hear that you're getting floods and maybe it's a little stinky now and it's a lot of tourists because the cruise ships and all the Venetians.
你知道的，天哪，真的是——真的是太神奇、太浪漫了。难以置信的时光。哇。你自蜜月之后再去过吗？其实没有，已经过去很久了。我们去过两次，那是——我们已经34年没回去了。是时候回去了。我觉得是时候了。是的，我不知道。我——我说别去打破它。时间。我不知道。我说顺其自然吧。什么？我说算了吧。不要重访故地？永远不要去重温一段回忆吗？好吧，那段回忆太美好了。太美好了。你知道我的意思吗？如果你回去了，然后你会想：哦天哪，这里有异味，而且……什么？我的意思是，无意冒犯威尼斯，但我听说你们现在经常发水灾，而且现在可能有点臭，因为有很多邮轮游客，还有所有的威尼斯人。
I've lost the whole amount of gondoliers that listen to the show. It's just incredible. We just lost a few. Well, I'm just saying, you know, a lot of time has passed and this is an amazing romantic memory. Maybe it should just stay there. I agree with you maybe in the church, in the concert, in the rain and all that. But I don't think you need to rule out all of Venice. I think there's maybe new places you could discover.
我失去了所有听节目的贡多拉船夫。简直难以置信。我们只是少了几个人。好吧，我的意思是，你知道的，过了很多年了，这是一段令人惊叹的浪漫回忆。也许它就应该停留在那里。我同意你的看法，也许就停留在教堂里、音乐会里、雨中以及所有那些情境中。但我不认为你需要把整个威尼斯都排除在外。我觉得也许还有你可以探索的新地方。
I think leave it. Okay, well, two very different takes on this memory. Okay, last question. They just asked three. Last question, do you speak any other languages other than English? We. We, whole whole.
我觉得就让它留在那里吧。好吧，对于这段回忆有两种截然不同的看法。好吧，最后一个问题。他们只问了三个。最后一个问题，除了英语之外，你还会说其他语言吗？我们会。我们，整个，整个。
I don't, actually. That was the extent of my French. No, I know a little bit of French and a little bit of Spanish, but that's one of the things I really, really do want to accomplish before I leave this earth, is to be able to expand my awareness and culture and not just be so American centric. You know, I want to step out of that.
其实我不会。那已经是我的法语极限了。不，我会一点法语和一点西班牙语，但这是我离开这个世界之前真正、真正想要完成的事情之一，那就是拓展我的眼界和文化，而不仅仅是以美国为中心。你知道，我想跳出那个圈子。
I spoke recently about not retiring, but taking a break. For the last 25 years, I've been working really nonstop and it's been great. As we know, it's wonderful and you're supported and you're having fun and you're engaged and it's artistic and creative and all those wonderful things, but it's not real life experience. You're going from one bubble to another bubble to another bubble. And I'm getting to a point where I feel like I'm a little depleted. Like my ideas aren't as fresh. They're a little harder to come by. And ooh, am I being derivative of another character that I've done?
我最近谈到了不退休，而是休息一段时间。在过去的25年里，我一直在不停地工作，感觉真的很棒。正如我们所知，这份工作很棒，你得到了支持，你在享受乐趣，你很投入，它具有艺术性和创造性以及所有这些美妙的特质，但这不是真实的生活体验。你从一个泡沫走进另一个泡沫，再走进另一个泡沫。我正到达这样一个阶段：我觉得自己有点被掏空了。就像我的灵感不像以前那么新鲜了。它们变得有点难以捕捉。而且，天哪，我是不是在抄袭我以前演过的另一个角色？
And can I break out of that? I needed more, I need more influences to come in so that it's more reciprocal. Right now there's been a lot of outflow for the last two decades and I think I need some real life experience to be able to say, oh I've never even thought of that before. I want to read that classic novel that I've always sworn I was of that before. I wanna read that classic novel that I've always sworn I was gonna read. I wanna learn how to cook.
我能突破这一点吗？我需要更多的影响注入进来，这样才能形成更多的双向互动。过去二十年来，输出已经太多了，我想我需要一些真实的生活体验，能够让我说：哦，我以前从来没想过这个。我想读那本我一直发誓要读的经典小说。我想读那本我一直发誓要读的经典小说。我想学做饭。
I wanna learn a language. I want to be in another culture and I don't wanna talk about show business. Yeah, we had an amazing conversation with Zach Woods and we were talking about this exact thing where we were saying that as artists, you need a life to feed your art You can't stay in just an art-making bubble No, because it's through our observations of other people and things and it's through going to that
我想学一门语言。我想置身于另一种文化中，我不想谈论娱乐圈。是的，我们和扎克·伍兹有过一次精彩的对话，我们谈论的正是这件事：作为艺术家，你需要生活来滋养你的艺术。你不能只待在艺术创作的泡沫里。不，因为正是通过我们对其他人和事物的观察，正是通过去参加那场
weird cousin's wedding That you get your ideas and your inspiration. And I would extend that even to, I remember Jerry Seinfeld doing an interview about this, talking about how much of his comedy comes from the frustrations and little annoyances in his life, standing in a line or someone, you know, budding in front of you as you've been waiting for a lot, you know,
古怪表亲的婚礼，你才获得了灵感和创意。我甚至想把这一点延伸开来，我记得杰瑞·宋飞（Jerry Seinfeld）做过一个关于此的访谈，谈到他的喜剧有多少来自于他生活中的挫折和小烦恼，比如排队时遇到有人插队，或者当你等了很久却有人，你知道的，
all those little ways that you watch how different people handle these every day, very universal situations, they inform you. They inform your art. And you, like you said, when you go from set to set to set or bubble to bubble to bubble, you start losing all those. And those are the things that we use to make our characters.
所有那些通过观察不同的人如何处理这些日常的、非常普遍的情况的小方式，它们都会给你启发。它们启发了你的艺术。而你，就像你说的，当你从一个片场转到另一个片场，从一个泡沫转到另一个泡沫时，你开始失去所有这些。而这些正是我们用来塑造角色的东西。
I used to joke that I haven't changed. I've had great good fortune in this business, but I really haven't changed. My dresser still puts on my pants one leg at a time. Good. He really does. He does a good job. You're valid. You're valid. It's my valid. You're valid.
我过去常常开玩笑说我没有变。我在这个行业里有很好的运气，但我真的没有变。我的化妆师依然是一条腿一条腿地帮我穿裤子。很好。他确实做得很棒。你很有价值。你很有价值。这是我应得的。你很有价值。
I traveled a lot growing up. My dad was a drilling engineer. I grew up in Jakarta and we moved around a lot. But recently I found an old travel journal that I kept as a young gal. And I read a little bit of it on the podcast. I was very snarky about a man who sat next to me who was taking a lot of notes about how to play poker on his napkin, but he would cover them so I couldn't see him. And I was like, what's up with this guy? And I had a whole journal of paper and I would have given him a piece of paper, but he kept hiding his notes. So I didn't. It was like this weird like retaliation I had with him. But the story has a point which is as I go back and look at that
我从小就去过很多地方旅行。我爸爸是一名钻井工程师。我在雅加达长大，我们搬过很多次家。但最近我发现了一本年轻时自己写的旧旅行日记。我在播客上读了一小段。对于坐在我旁边的一个男人，我当时写得非常刻薄，他在餐巾纸上记了大量关于怎么玩扑克牌的笔记，但他会把它们遮住不让我看。当时我想：这家伙搞什么鬼？我有一整本纸质日记，如果他要的话我会分给他一张纸，但他一直藏着自己的笔记。所以我没给。这就像是我跟他之间的一种古怪的报复行为。但这个故事的重点在于，当我回头看那本
journal of travel and seeing other things and experiencing other things, I just crave it. And like, I want to, I want to like sit next to the guy on the plane who is taking notes on his napkin. What's that about? Now, what's interesting though is that now you have to hope that you're not recognized in order to have a legitimate conversation. Otherwise, it's weighted and it's not the same thing. Celebrity is a strange thing as we know. It makes people nervous, anxious, giddy, excited. They can't stop. They can't believe it. I mean, how many people have said, I can't believe I'm meeting you? Blowing my mind. Well, that's not the way that person normally behaves. So there's no way that you're going to have a normal conversation with that person.
旅行日记，看到其他事物并体验其他事物时，我只是极度渴望这种经历。就像，我想去——我想坐在飞机上那个在餐巾纸上记笔记的家伙旁边。那到底是怎么回事？不过有趣的是，现在你必须祈祷自己不要被认出来，才能进行一次真正的对话。否则，对话就会变得有心理负担，不再是那么回事了。正如我们所知，名气是一件奇怪的事。它让人们感到紧张、焦虑、飘飘然、兴奋。他们无法停下来。他们简直不敢相信。我是说，有多少人说过：我不敢相信我正在见你？这太让我震惊了。好吧，那并不是那个人正常的行为方式。所以你根本不可能和那个人进行正常的对话。
So I always used to look for old people. If I were in a, some people who didn't know, chances are it wouldn't know who I am. And that way, I knew I was getting an authentic conversation. Oh yeah. I mean, I do, I do. I do. One of my favorite cities is New York and one of my favorite things to do is just people watch. And so I love to go hide out in Central Park and just watch everything unfold in front of me.
所以我总是去寻找老年人。如果我在一个地方，有些人不认识我，大概率是不会知道我是谁的。通过这种方式，我知道我能得到一场真实的对话。哦，是的。我是说，我的确，我的确。我最喜欢的城市之一是纽约，我最喜欢做的事情之一就是观察行人。所以我喜欢去中央公园躲起来，静静地看着身边的这一切上演。
And that's something I find, I can, you can still go unrecognized. And if you wear your hat, and you don't make a big fuss about yourself. And you're big red nose. Yes, that's right. And you're floppy shoes. big fuss about yourself. And you're being red nose. Yes, that's right. And you're floppy shoes.
而且我发现，你可以，你还是可以不被认出来。只要你戴上帽子，不要太引人注目。还有你那标志性的大红鼻子。是的，没错。还有你那双大头鞋。不要太引人注目。还有你那标志性的大红鼻子。是的，没错。还有你那双大头鞋。
And you're wig. And you're sign. That's right. And then I smoke. You know, we know I don't smoke in real life. Start making balloon animals. You know, they won't know who you are. I feel the same way when I go to, my family has a farm in Archer City, Texas, and there's
还有你的假发。还有你的牌子。没错。然后我抽烟。你知道的，我们在现实生活中都知道我不抽烟。开始用气球捏动物。你知道的，他们不会知道你是谁。当我去的、我的家人在得克萨斯州阿彻市有一个农场时，我也有同感，那里有
a little cafe, Mern's, because the woman who runs it is named Mern. And, you know, it's great. I go in there and it's just everyone that's been working cattle and they're all in there. And it's, I just love it. No one knows the show. Do they have your picture up on the wall?
一个小咖啡馆，叫 Mern's，因为经营它的那个女人叫 Mern。而且，你知道的，这感觉太棒了。我走进去，里面全是在放牛的人，他们都在那儿。而且，我真是爱极了。没有人知道这部剧。他们把你的照片挂在墙上了吗？
No, heck no. No, they have like- Come on, Mern. They have the starting lineup of the football team and the cheerleaders and whoever is, you know, doing well at 4-H Club that year. It's... That's rather sweet. Yeah, it is.
不，见鬼，没有。不，他们有——拜托，Mern。他们有橄榄球队的首发阵容、啦啦队，还有那年在4-H俱乐部表现出色的人。这……这相当温馨。是的，确实如此。
It's great. I used to travel a lot by motorcycle. In the 70s, I traveled across the country. For two years, I was on a motorcycle. Wow. And I would get odd jobs here and there. In the 70s, you could do that. Ladies wouldn't know that.
这太棒了。我以前经常骑摩托车旅行。在70年代，我曾骑车穿过全国。有两年时间，我都骑着摩托车。哇。我会在各地找点零工做。在70年代，你是可以这么做的。女士们可能不知道这一点。
Because you're way too young. And at one time, I took Route 66 from California, Santa Monica to Chicago. And on the way back, I took this Route 50, which is called the Loneliest Highway. You go through Nebraska, Kansas, the places that people, for the most part, they go, well, there's nothing really to see there, so I won't avoid it. I want to go there. We're going through Kansas in a little place called Peabody, Kansas. It's flat, it's small. There's a bank on the corner, there's a coffee shop, and
因为你们太年轻了。有一次，我沿着66号公路从加利福尼亚的圣莫尼卡开到芝加哥。在回来的路上，我走了50号公路，被称为“最孤独的公路”。你要穿过内布拉斯加州、堪萨斯州，那些人们大部分都会觉得，“嗯，那里其实没什么好看的，所以我还是绕开它吧”的地方。我想去那里。我们要穿过堪萨斯州一个叫皮博迪的小地方。那里很平坦，很小。街角有一家银行，有一家咖啡馆，而且
in the coffee shop they list everybody's birthday for that day. And I said, these are the people who work here? And I go, no, that's people in the entire town. We have such a small town that they list everyone's birthday on that particular day. It's really, and it's quaint and sweet. And by the way, speaking of birthdays, we share a birthday. You do, your birthday wedding is. We are, we interviewed Tim Meadows for the podcast
在咖啡馆里，他们列出了当天过生日的所有人的名字。我说，这些都是在这里工作的人吗？我说，不对，那是全镇所有的人。我们镇子太小了，以至于他们会把那天过生日的每个人的名字都列出来。真的，这既古朴又温馨。顺便说一句，说到生日，我们俩同一天生日。真的吗，你的生日是……我们是，我们为播客采访了蒂姆·梅多斯
and we were all talking about our celebrity birthday partner. And I said you. Yes. I know, happy birthday, happy early birthday. March 7 said you. I know. Happy birthday. Well, not yet. Well, not yet. March 7th. March 7th.
然后我们都在谈论和自己同一天生日的名人搭档。我说是你。是的。我知道，生日快乐，提前祝你生日快乐。3月7日，我说是你。我知道。生日快乐。嗯，还没到。嗯，还没到。3月7日。3月7日。
Yeah. Same year? Yes, 74. Yeah, that's right. This is my big 50th birthday this year. Are you welcoming it? It's going to come whether you want to or not, but... I am welcoming it. You're saying bring it on world. Yeah, I'm saying bring it on.
对。同一年？是的，74年。对，没错。今年是我满50岁的大寿。你欢迎它的到来吗？不管你愿不愿意，它都会来，但是……我非常欢迎。你是说，生活尽管放马过来吧。是的，我说尽管放马过来吧。
I'm doing big party. I'm happy to celebrate my 50th. I'm excited about it. I find it very liberating. I think it's great. You look fantastic. You both look great. I am 52.
我要办个盛大的派对。我很高兴能庆祝我的50大寿。我对此感到很兴奋。我发现这非常解放天心。我觉得这太棒了。你看起来棒极了。你们两个看起来都很好。我52岁了。
I will be 53. I love my 50s. I love it. I told Jenna it's the zero Fs. She's making it look a lot of fun. It's my zero F's chapter of my life. Super fun. I guess if it was truly my zero F's, I'd say zero f***, right?
我将要53岁。我喜欢我的50岁。我太喜欢了。我告诉珍娜，这就是“零内耗”。她把它过得很有趣。这是我人生的“零内耗”篇章。超级有趣。我想如果这真的是我的零内耗，我会说“零他妈的烦恼”，对吧？
We like to keep it clean on office. We keep it clean. We have a lot of young listeners. Yeah. I'll bet you do. We do. The age range is like really big. There's rumor that you probably already talked about.
我们喜欢在节目里保持干净。我们保持干净。我们有很多年轻听众。是的，我敢说你们确实有。我们确实有。年龄跨度真的很大。有传言说，你们可能已经讨论过了
There's rumor of doing a reboot. Yes, we hear Greg is working on something. Yeah, he's cooking something up. But it's not involving the same cast, we should say that. Yeah. But I would love to pop on as a guest. Ooh, me too. I'd love to be a guest on some sort of next gen. Yeah, or something like
有重启的传言。是的，我们听说格雷格正在筹备什么。是的，他正在酝酿什么。但我们得说，这不会涉及原来的演员阵容。是的。但我很乐意作为嘉宾客串一下。哦，我也是！我很乐意在某种下一代节目中做嘉宾。是的，或者诸如此类
that. That would be great. But I don't see bringing Pam back in a sort of permanent way and following her life again. At least it hasn't. But you know, Greg Daniels is a person who could think it up and pitch it to me and get me on board. So, but I can't think of it. Right. Yeah. You know, so if Dunder Mifflin still existed, there'd be other people working there. Maybe. We think Creed would still be there. Brian and Oscar and I, our little accounting clump, we used to have this pitch that we would be the spin-offs, but it would be on Telemundo and it'd be like, Los Acatadores, Oscar Enjala y Kevin.
那会很棒。但我不认为能以某种永久的方式把帕姆带回来并再次追踪她的生活。至少现在还没有。但你知道，格雷格·丹尼尔斯是一个能想出这个点子，并向我推销并让我加入的人。所以，但我自己想不出来。对。是的，所以如果邓德米夫林仍然存在，那里还会有其他人工作。也许吧。我们认为克里德还会留在那里。布莱恩、奥斯卡和我，我们这个小小的主管会计小分队，我们以前有个点子，就是我们可以拍衍生剧，但要在西班牙语电视台播出，就像是、奥斯卡、安吉拉和凯文。
And I would do that. I would do the Telemundo reboot of the accounts. Telemundo. Telemundo. Brian, what do you get approached about the most? Breaking Bad. Breaking Bad. Yeah. Yeah, still.
我会演那个。我会演会计们的西班牙语电视台重启版。西班牙语电视台。西班牙语电视台。布莱恩，你最常被问到的是什么？《绝命毒师》。《绝命毒师》。是啊。是的，依然如此。
I guess the most fervent fan base. Do you get pictures of people on Halloween dressed as Walter White? All the time. Yeah, we get that too. It's a crazy thing. You get pictures of people on Halloween dressed as Walter White? All the time. All the time. Yeah, we get that too. Yeah. It's a crazy thing. You get pictures of Walter White for a movie?
我猜这是最狂热的粉丝群体。你有没有收到万圣节时人们打扮成沃尔特·怀特的照片？整天都有。是的，我们也有。这太疯狂了。你有没有收到万圣节时人们打扮成沃尔特·怀特的照片？整天都有。整天都有。是的，我们也有。这太疯狂了。你有没有收到沃尔特·怀特电影的照片？
I do. I do. Yeah. People want me to know. But she holds a cat. Yeah. My Walter White. That's a crazy thing to have been on a show that endures.
我有。我有。是的。人们想让我知道。但她抱着一只猫。是的。我的沃尔特·怀特。能参演一部经久不衰的剧集，这太疯狂了。
I just rewatched Breaking Bad. I got COVID and it was my COVID comfort show. Let's see where... I watched it during the pandemic. This was my rewatch because it is my opinion that Breaking Bad is the single greatest television pilot ever. I stand by that statement.
我最近刚重温了《绝命毒师》。我得了新冠，这是我的新冠慰藉剧。让我们看看……我在大流行期间看了它。这是我的重温，因为在我看来，《绝命毒师》是电视史上最伟大的试播集。我坚持这个观点。
And I have loved rewatching it. And people still rewatch it, right. And people still rewatch it, right? And people still rewatch the office. And it's such a cool thing to be part of something that endures like that, I think. It's truly legendary shows. We're both all very fortunate to be chosen to be on such a thing.
我非常喜欢重温它。人们仍然在重温它，对吧。人们仍然在重温它，对吧？人们仍然在重温《办公室》。而且，能成为像这样经久不衰的作品的一部分，是一件非常酷的事，我认为。这真的是传奇般的剧集。我们都非常幸运能被选中参演这样一部作品。
And as people have always asked you, I'm sure that always asked me, did you know it was going to be a big hit? And you go, no, it was a job. I was happy to read this great script. You two were like, this sounds crazy. This sounds fun. I don't know exactly how it's going to work. And let me ask you this, on the first year of the office,
正如人们一直问你的，我确信他们也一直问我，“你知道它会大获成功吗？”然后你会说，“不，这只是一份工作。我很高兴能读到这个棒极了的剧本。”你们两个当时觉得：这听起来太疯狂了。这听起来很有趣。我不知道它究竟会如何运作。让我问你这个，《办公室》第一年的时候，
what were the ratings like? I mean, was it- A bismol. Our first season was six episodes. And we were going to get- Shit can't. For sure. We were gonna get canceled, but then that summer,
收视率怎么样？我是说，它——糟透了。我们的第一季只有六集。我们肯定会被——砍掉。肯定的。我们肯定会被砍掉，但后来在那年夏天，
between season one and deciding if we would get picked up for season two, the 40-year-old virgin came out and Steve Carell became a massive box office comedy star. And I think NBC was like, I'm sorry, you don't cut loose. The number one comedy box office star. Yeah. Yeah. You pick up that show.
在第一季结束和决定我们是否会被续订第二季之间，《四十岁的老处男》上映了，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔成为了一个巨大的票房喜剧明星。我想NBC当时的想法是，抱歉，你不能放走这个全美第一的喜剧票房明星。是的。是的。你得续订那个节目。
It was still only a little bit, not a full season for season two. Yeah. And Phyllis and I used to call the ratings hotline. We used to run on Tuesday. This is how old we are. Old Tech Alliance. Ratings hotline, may I help you? We would run on Tuesdays originally. Before we moved to Must See TV, we were on Tuesdays and every Wednesday morning we would get on set and Phyllis and I would listen to the recording
但第二季仍然只有一小部分，不是完整的一季。是的。菲莉丝和我过去常常打收视率热线。我们每周二看播出。这就是我们有多老。老科技联盟。收视率热线，有什么我可以帮您的吗？我们最初是在周二播出。在我们转到“必看电视”时段之前，我们是在周二播出，每周三早上我们一到片场，菲莉丝和我就会听录音，
and we knew that as long as we had like a 2.4 or above, we still had jobs. And we would just hold our breath and wait for the recording to tell us what our ratings were. Yeah. And it was like that for into the second season. Every week I would send out a mass email. I was like, that first thing.
而且我们知道，只要我们的收视率在2.4或以上，我们就还有工作。我们就会屏住呼吸，等待录音告诉我们收视率是多少。是的。直到第二季都是这样。每周我都会群发一封电子邮件。我就像那样，第一件事。
I was like, hey, you guys, can you guys please watch our show this week? It really means a lot. Thanks so much. Everyone I knew from all my improv days, all my theater days, everyone back home. And then finally it was around the first Christmas episode, Yankee Swap. One of my friends wrote back and said, I don't think you need to send these anymore. You're going to be okay. You're gonna be okay. You're being a little annoying. Yeah, I stopped sending these emails.
我就像，嘿，伙计们，你们这周能看我们的节目吗？这真的意义重大。非常感谢。我所有从即兴表演、剧院认识的人，家乡的每个人。然后终于到了第一个圣诞节那一集，即兴交换礼物。我的一个朋友回信说，我觉得你不需要再发这些了。你会没事的。你会没事的。你有点烦人。是的，我停止发送这些邮件了。
What about was Breaking Bad big in the ratings at first? No, not at all. No, we're on a cable channel, AMC. We weren't big hits at all. Although, like the critics really, really loved us. So we had that, but that doesn't equate to being commercially successful. What happened for us was a stroke of really good fortune and that was in 2009, Netflix switched from the red envelopes where they would send you the
《绝命毒师》一开始的收视率很高吗？没有，一点也不。没有，我们在有线电视台AMC播出。我们一点也不红。尽管评论家们真的非常非常喜欢我们。所以我们有这个优势，但这并不等同于商业上的成功。对我们来说发生的是一次极好的运气，那就是在2009年，Netflix从红信封转向了——以前他们会把
movies at once. Remember the mail them to streaming to where you can push a button on a computer. It changed technology, it changed availability and Breaking Bad's second season. We had two seasons and we're like, I don't know if it's going to go a third. Well, maybe we'll let them go with that. And all of a sudden, everybody started to go, was able to go back and watch the first episode and then just start watching them all. And then that's what caught on. So really, it was Netflix that was the stroke of good luck for us.
电影一次性寄给你。还记得他们寄到流媒体吗，你可以在电脑上按一个按钮。它改变了技术，改变了收视方式，而《绝命毒师》正值第二季。我们拍了两季，心想，不知道它能不能拍第三季。好吧，也许我们就让他们就此结束吧。突然之间，每个人都开始去，能够回去看第一集，然后就开始把所有的都看了。然后这就流行起来了。所以真的，Netflix对我们来说就是那场好运。
For us too, kind of. It's why we've endured since the show went off the air. Let me ask you this because I seem to remember this and I'm not completely positive. But when Ricky Gervais' version of the original Office, his character was caustic and mean-spirited and rude and biting and all those things. And Steve's character, when it first started, had more of a flavor of an edge to him, didn't it? When I first started watching it, it was more of like, ooh, and I think at some point,
对我们来说也是，某种程度上。这就是为什么自从剧集停播后我们一直坚挺到现在。让我问你这个，因为我好像还记得这件事，我不是百分之百确定。但是当瑞奇·热维斯版本的原版《办公室》里，他的角色是刻薄、恶毒、粗鲁、尖锐以及所有这些时，史蒂夫的角色刚开始的时候，是不是更有棱角一点？当我刚开始看的时候，它更像是那种，噢，而且我想在某个时刻，
and I'm asking as a fan, at what point did they go, well, let's make a, let's turn the dial on this a little bit and give him more of that confident, indisul, kind of level and not mean-spirited. That happened in that transition from season one to season two. I think people saw this lovable quality to his character and 40-year-old virgin, and they also just started writing the show more to Steve and less to the template that Ricky had laid down
我是作为粉丝在问，他们在哪个时刻决定，好吧，让我们稍微调整一下，让这个角色表现出更多那种自信、无厘头、某种水平，而不是那么恶毒？那发生在第一季到第二季的过渡中。我想人们从他的角色和《四十岁的老处男》中看到了这种可爱的特质，而且他们开始更多地为史蒂夫写剧本，而不是照搬瑞奇对大卫·布伦特这个角色设定的模板。
with his character of David Brent. And so there was a little bit of a retooling, but we also got some really good advice from Ricky Gervais who said, hey, you know, in America, you guys like to do hundreds of episodes of shows. And David Brent doesn't work for hundreds of episodes. Like you can't like have that character do this
所以有过一些微调，但我们也得到了瑞奇·热维斯非常好的建议，他说：“嘿，你知道的，在美利坚，你们喜欢拍几百集的剧集。而大卫·布伦特并不适合拍几百集。就像你不能让这个角色做这种事
for that long. So you're gonna need to find more layers to your lead character or he's gonna burn out. And also so true, so smart. The writer's room also did something that I thought really worked for American audiences is each episode has one redeeming moment. One moment where it's either Pam listening to Jim's messages as she drives home and there's a montage, or it's Dwight getting a pat on the shoulder from Michael, even though the whole day they were like fighting. There's one little moment,
持续那么久。所以你们需要为你们的主角找到更多的层次，否则他会精疲力竭的。”这也太对了，太聪明了。编剧室还做了一件事，我认为对美国观众真的很有效，那就是每一集都有一个救赎的时刻。某个时刻，要么是帕姆在开车回家时听着吉姆的留言，同时有一段蒙太奇，要么是德怀特得到迈克尔拍拍肩膀，尽管整整一天他们都在吵架。只有一个小小的时刻，
and it doesn't have to be a huge one, but each episode has one. So you're saying that this was a concerted effort. This was a note that every episode we want to have at least one redeeming quality come out of it. Yeah, one moment. A moment of hope. A hopeful moment.
而且它不必是一个巨大的时刻，但每一集都有一个。所以你是说，这是一次齐心协力的努力。这是一个要求，即每一集我们都希望至少有一个救赎的特质从中体现出来。是的，一个时刻。一个充满希望的时刻。一个充满希望的时刻。
A hopeful moment within all of it. Moment of zen. Yes. Look at that. I didn't know that. Yeah. And if you, now if I go back and watch, I see it, I can find them.
在这一切之中的充满希望的时刻。禅意时刻。是的。你看。我以前不知道。是的。如果你现在回头看，我能看出来，我能找到它们。
I'm like, oh, well that kind of made me feel better about that, to that work bus day. We got to have pie. We got to sit outside. We got to have pie. Was that our moment? Yeah. We got pie at the end?
我会想，哦，好吧，那让我对那个工作巴士日感觉好了一点。我们得吃派。我们得坐在外面。我们得吃派。那是我们的时刻吗？是的。我们最后吃派了吗？
Yeah, the montage at the end of pie. Well, there's another moment in this episode that I actually love, which is Jim and Dwight up on the roof of the bus. Oh, yes. And I love any moment when, you know, that these rivals, these guys who are always, you know, Jim's always pranking Dwight and everything. But when there's this moment where Dwight gets vulnerable and Jim is there to catch him. And I love that. That was a really beautiful scene. That's true because that exposes the audience
是的，结尾吃派的蒙太奇。嗯，这一集里还有另一个我真的很喜欢的时刻，那就是吉姆和德怀特在巴士的屋顶上。哦，是的。我喜欢任何这样的时刻，你知道，这些对手，这些总是——你知道吉姆总是捉弄德怀特和一切。但当有这样一个时刻，德怀特变得脆弱，而吉姆在那里接住他。我喜欢那个。那真的是非常美妙的一幕。那是真的，因为这向观众展现了
to the true character of Jim. And that he's, when it's necessary, when someone expresses vulnerability like that, it's like he doesn't come in for the kill. Yeah. He backs off and actually lends support. Oh, see? It's very sweet.
吉姆的真实性格。那就是当有必要时，当有人表达出这种脆弱时，他并没有落井下石。是的。他退后一步，实际上给予了支持。噢，你看？这非常温馨。
I had a few moments like that. You know, we kind of, I mean, so let's say that there's not a reboot series, but what if there was like a movie? Like Downton Abbey, the movie? Yeah, something to where we can see where these people are, these people in the entire cast that we're curious about. We wondered at the end, where did they go?
我有过几个那样的时刻。你知道的，我们有点，我是说，所以假设没有重启系列，但如果有一部电影呢？就像《唐顿庄园》大电影那样？是的，某种能让我们看到这些人都在哪里的方式，我们一直好奇的整个演员阵容。我们在最后想知道，他们去哪儿了？
What did become of them? I mean, I'd do it. I would do it. I would do it for my kids, because I think they would think that's fun. I mean, if Greg did it because I would trust it. Yes. You know, 100% for sure, because I would trust it. Yes, 100%. For sure. Greg is signed on in this hypothetical.
他们最终成了什么样？我是说，我会演的。我会演的。我会为了我的孩子们演，因为我觉得他们会觉得这很有趣。我是说，如果格雷格来拍，因为我会信任它。是的。你知道的，百分之百确定，因为我会信任它。是的，100%。肯定的。在这个假设中，格雷格已经签约了。
Okay, as long as Greg is writing it and he's in charge of it, then I say yes. Okay. Enough said. Brian Cranston. Let's get Greg on the phone. Bitch, he's our new agent. I just wanna be an extra in it.
好吧，只要格雷格在写剧本并且由他负责，那我就会说好。好吧。无需多言。布莱恩·克兰斯顿。我们把格雷格叫来。妈的，他成了我们的新经纪人了。我只想在里面演个群众演员。
I do. You have to be in it. I would be an extra in it. I do. You have to be in it. I would be an extra in it. I would be some guy. I'd be like a crossing guard or something like that. Maybe you're like one of Dwight's hired hands on troop farms. On his farm? Now, why would I be the hired hand and not the foreman?
我是认真的。你必须得演。我会演个群众演员的。我是认真的。你必须得演。我会演个群众演员的。我会演某个路人甲。我会演个交通协管员或者类似的角色。也许你就像是德怀特在施鲁特农场雇用的帮工之一。在他的农场里？那为什么我是雇工而不是领班呢？
Thank you. It's just how we see you. It's just like a tight- It's like, look at that old guy. He's just a higher man. Why is he having to bail hay? He's an old man and they're making him bail hay. Oh, that's right. That's not the moment of zen. That's not a nice moment at all.
谢谢。这就是我们对你的看法。这就像是一个紧凑的——这就像是，看那个老头。他只是个雇工。为什么他非得去打捆稻草？他是个老头，他们却逼他打捆稻草。哦，对了。那可不是禅意时刻。那可一点也不是什么好时刻。
Are there any projects you're working on right now that we can share with our listeners? We know you're working on the project of living life. The project of living life? That's a good way to put it. I really do need to do that. I'm very fortunate that I'm in a position where I'm getting a lot of offers, both for theater and films and television and things. And so I just have to pick and choose what is new to me and challenging. I don't want to do something that I've done before.
有什么你现在正在参与的项目可以和我们的听众分享吗？我们知道你正在参与“体验生活”这个项目。“体验生活”这个项目？这倒是个好说法。我确实需要这么做。我很幸运，我现在的处境让我能接到很多邀约，无论是戏剧、电影、电视还是其他方面。所以我只需要精挑细选对我来说是全新的、有挑战性的东西。我不想做我以前做过的事。
And the more I go without that real life experience, the harder that is to find because I haven't changed. It's like you were saying, like if a band just played the same music over and over and they never expanded, they never wrote beyond what they were. Like you look at the Beatles and they weren't together all that long, but they expanded and expressed themselves in so many different ways, whatever they were going through,
而且我越是没有那种现实生活经验，这就越难找到，因为我没有改变。就像你刚才说的，如果一支乐队只是反反复复演奏同一首音乐，却从不拓展，从不超越他们原有的水平。就像你看披头士乐队，他们在一起的时间其实并没有那么长，但他们拓展了自己，用各种不同的方式表达自己，无论他们经历着什么，
it was infused in their art. And I kind of want to do that. I want to get out of the bubble a little bit. So that's that. But before that may happen, there's responsibilities I have. I have a Mascall company with Aaron Paul, and Dos Ombras, which is...
都会融入到他们的艺术中。而我也想那样。我想稍微跳出这个舒适圈。这就是情况。但在那之前，我还有责任在身。我和亚伦·保罗开了一家梅斯卡尔酒公司，叫Dos Omres，也就是……
Oh, wow! Yeah. And had I been a great guest, I would have brought you some. company with Aaron Paul and Dos Omres. I saw that. Dos Omres. Yeah. And had I been a great guest, I would have brought you some. Damn it. I forgot. But that's going well. It's this business I've never thought I'd be in.
噢，哇！是的。如果我是一个优秀的嘉宾，我本该带一些给你的。公司，和亚伦·保罗一起，还有Dos Omres。我看到了。Dos Omres。是的。如果我是一个优秀的嘉宾，我本该带一些给你的。该死。我给忘了。不过进展很顺利。这是我从未想过自己会涉足的行业。
We'll share about it in our Office Ladies Pods series. It's so good. It's so good. Did you get to go like do a tasting? Did you get to be part of the formula? Yeah. How does that work? Yeah.
我们会在我们的“办公室女士”播客系列中分享它的。太棒了。太棒了。你有去品酒吗？你有参与配方的研发吗？是的。那是怎么运作的？是的。
Well, here's Aaron and I, three years after the end of Breaking Bad, we missed each other. And you know, it's like when you leave. We can relate. Holly, yeah. Yeah. You're together, you're together, you're together. It ends and life goes on and sends you in
好吧，这里是亚伦和我，在《绝命毒师》结束三年后，我们互相想念。你知道的，就像当你离开。我们能感同身受。霍莉，是的。是的。你们在一起，在一起，在一起。结束了，生活继续，然后把你们送向
different directions. And we happen to be in New York City at the same time and we have to have dinner. So we're having dinner and we expressed how much we missed each other. And he said, you know, what we ought to do is have a company. We ought to have a Mascall company together. What? That's what I said. I go, what do you, that's random.
不同的方向。而我们碰巧同时在纽约市，我们必须一起吃个晚饭。所以我们在吃晚饭，我们表达了我们有多想念对方。他说，你知道的，我们应该做的是开一家公司。我们应该一起开一家梅斯卡尔酒公司。什么？这就是我说的。我说，你这是什么，太随机了吧。
What do you, that's terrible. That shitty spirit with a dead worm at the bottom. What are you talking about? And he goes, no, no, no, no. He took me to a Mascall bar in New York City. We sipped some of the greatest spirits that I've ever had. I don't think I've ever had mescal. Oh, so good.
你这是什么，这太糟糕了。那是底部带着一条死虫子的烂烈酒。你在说什么呢？他说，不，不，不，不。他带我去了一家纽约市的梅斯卡尔酒酒吧。我们品尝了我喝过的最棒的一些烈酒。我想我以前从未喝过梅斯卡尔酒。哦，太棒了。
It's the older brother of tequila. Okay. Tequila is a mescal. Okay. But mescal is not a tequila. A spirit like that, that's made from a agave plant is always a mescal. And the way they make tequila is to steam it and put it in a silo and it's more of a fast process.
它是龙舌兰酒的哥哥。好的。龙舌兰酒是一种梅斯卡尔酒。好的。但梅斯卡尔酒不是龙舌兰酒。像这种用龙舌兰植物制成的烈酒总是梅斯卡尔酒。而他们制作龙舌兰酒的方法是将其蒸气加热并放入筒仓中，这是一个更快速的过程。
Mezcal is smoked and so it's in an earthen pit for four days and then mashed. In fact, ours, we have, it says artisanal on the bottle and there's no modern technology used in the process of this or else we can't say that on the bottle. So it's the old-fashioned way. It goes from that to a rock pit where two donkeys pull this big rock wheel and mash this now smoked agave. Then it ferments in an oak barrel for 10 days,
梅斯卡尔酒是熏制的，所以它要在土坑里放四天然后捣碎。事实上，我们的瓶子上写着“手工制作”，在这个过程中没有使用任何现代技术，否则我们不能在瓶子上这样写。所以这是老式的方法。它从那儿运到一个岩石坑里，两头驴拉着这个巨大的石轮，把这个现在已经熏制过的龙舌兰捣碎。然后它在一个橡木桶中发酵10天，
and then it goes into a copper kettle for a distillation. And that's the purity of it. It's mountain spring water and smoked agave. That's all that's in it. And it's done, Dos Omres is now the fifth largest mescal in the world. Come on! That is so amazing.
然后它进入一个铜制大锅进行蒸馏。这就是它的纯净之处。那是高山泉水和熏制的龙舌兰。这就是里面所有的东西。而且它完成了，Dos Omres现在已经是世界第五大梅斯卡尔酒品牌了。拜托！这太惊人了。
We have to try it. We have to try it. We have to try it. We're going to go get some. I will bring it to you. Yay! I will bring it to you. Yay. I will bring it to you.
我们必须尝尝。我们必须尝尝。我们必须尝尝。我们要去买一些。我会带给你的。耶！我会带给你的。耶。我会带给你的。
Even better. I love this. Yeah, that's really good. Also, just your description of it. Just, I don't know. I felt like I left my body for a minute. It felt like I went on a little vacation. I know.
更好。我喜欢这个。是的，这真的很棒。还有，光是你的听觉描述。只是，我不知道。我觉得我有一分钟灵魂出窍了。感觉就像我去度了个小假。我知道。
A journey. And we did. We went down to Oaxaca. We found this spirit and brought it to the marketplace. In truth, the spirit found us because it's been around for hundreds of years and we were just there to receive it. This sounds like a pretty good start
一次旅程。我们确实去了。我们去了瓦哈卡。我们找到了这款烈酒并把它带到了市场上。事实上，是烈酒找到了我们，因为它已经存在了几百年，而我们只是去接受它。这听起来是个相当不错的开端
on the project of living life. Yeah. It is, but like any other business, it takes a lot of effort, a lot of time and energy. Probably more than you expected when you started. And it's a lot of effort, a lot of time and energy. Probably more than you expected when you started. And it's a lot of work. And I find that the business end of it, the case cells and this, it's not as interesting to me as the process of making it and that nurturing sense.
关于体验生活这个项目。是的。确实是，但就像任何其他生意一样，它需要大量的努力、大量的时间和精力。可能比你刚开始时预期的要多。而且这需要付出大量的努力、大量的时间和精力。可能比你刚开始时预期的要多。这是一项繁重的工作。我发现其中的商业部分，比如案例销售这些，对我来说不如制作它的过程和那种培育感那么有趣。
Yeah, that and I have a production company and that's interesting too and it's good. But I'm now looking for ways to have more of that human real life experience. I have a crazy question for you. Oh. Did you ever in your young artist's life ever do that book, The Artist's Way? No.
是的，除此之外我还有一家制作公司，那也很有趣，而且很好。但我现在在寻找能够获得更多那种人类真实生活体验的方法。我有一个疯狂的问题要问你。哦。你年轻的艺术生涯中做过那本书吗，《艺术家的方式》？没有。
Julia Cameron? No. Excellent. I highly recommend it. I highly recommend it. Jenna did it twice. I did a few pages of it. And how did the few pages go?
茱莉亚·卡梅伦？没有。太棒了。我强烈推荐它。我强烈推荐它。珍娜做过两次。我做了其中的几页。那这几页做得怎么样？
Fantastic. We're different persons. I did it twice because the first time I didn't finish and it bothered me so deeply because I realized that one of my challenges in my early artistic life was having tons of great ideas of which I finished none. And so I thought I need to get over this finishing things problem.
棒极了。我们是不同的人。我做了两次，因为第一次我没有做完，这深深地困扰着我，因为我意识到我早年艺术生涯的挑战之一就是拥有无数伟大的想法，却没有完成其中任何一个。所以我当时想，我需要克服这个无法完成事情的问题。
Why don't I start by finishing the artist's way? Right, and so I thought I need to get over this finishing things problem. Right. Why don't I start by finishing the artist's way? Yes, yes. And so I had done 10 of the 12 weeks and I went back and I started over again. I did all 12 weeks and there are still things from that book, even today as an artist, that I think of it.
为什么我不能从完成《艺术家的方式》开始呢？对，所以我当时想，我需要克服这个无法完成事情的问题。对。为什么我不能从完成《艺术家的方式》开始呢？是的，是的。所以我完成了12周中的10周，然后我回过头重新开始。我完成了所有的12周，直到今天，作为一名艺术家，那本书里仍然有些东西是我会想到的。
You know, one of the things is once a week you have to go on an artist's date. Alone by yourself, just you, that could be going to a symphony. That could be sitting in a park and watching people. That could be- I love that. Taking yourself bowling alone. Like whatever your artist date is,
你知道，其中一件事就是每周你必须进行一次“艺术家约会”。独自一人，只有你自己，那可以是去听一场交响乐。那可以是在公园里坐着观察人们。那可以是——我喜欢那个。独自一人去保龄球馆。无论你的艺术家约会是什么，
you have to do this once a week. But it's all creative, it's all artistic. And so sometimes when I'm like starting a new artistic journey or whatever, I'll refer back and I'll do an artist state and I'll try to kickstart something. It's that business of living life, right? That's fantastic.
你必须每周做一次。但这完全是创造性的，完全是艺术性的。所以有时当我开始一段新的艺术旅程或什么的，我会回过头去参考它，进行一次艺术家约会，试图重新启动某些东西。这就是生活经营的业务，对吧？这太棒了。
It's really awesome. The bowling part through me. The bowling, that's an artist state if you want it to be. Really? Oh yeah, take yourself bowling. And to be fair, the week I got the bark. Go to an art museum. it was the week of my birthday when I got this book as a gift,
这真的很赞。保龄球那部分让我有点意外。保龄球，如果你愿意的话，那就是一次艺术家约会。真的吗？哦，对，自己去打保龄球吧。公平地说，我拿到这本书的那周，去艺术博物馆。那是我的生日周，我得到了这本书作为礼物，
but I also got a pair of roller skates. And I was a child of the 70s and I love roller skating. And then I think I started it and then I was like, I'm gonna go roller skate. That could be an art estate. Well, it was an art estate that never stopped. It was an art estate that never, I still have the same pair of roller skates.
但我也得到了一双旱冰鞋。我是70年代的孩子，我喜欢轮滑。然后我想我开始了，然后我就想，我要去轮滑。那可以是一次艺术家约会。嗯，这是一次从未停止的艺术家约会。这是一次从未停止的艺术家约会，我至今仍留着同一双旱冰鞋。
They're by my front door. I still roller skate. That's got to be something, Jenna. That's great. That came out of the artist's way for me. I recon... I think it came out of your birthday. My birthday buddy is Ricky Gervais. Oh, look at that.
它们就在我的前门旁。我还在轮滑。那一定有什么意义，珍娜。这太棒了。那是《艺术家的方式》带给我的。我重新……我觉得那是你生日带来的。我的生日搭档是瑞奇·热维斯。哦，你看。
A little tie-in. I once told him that. He was like, okay. We also have Rachel Weiss. Oh. Oh, did she share our birthday as well? Yes. Uh, Peter Sarsgard. Mmm.
一个小小的连结。我曾经告诉过他。他的反应是，好吧。我们还有蕾切尔·薇兹。哦。哦，她也和我们同一天生日吗？是的。呃，彼得·萨斯加德。嗯。
This is exciting. I have busy Phillips. We should have a dinner. We should have a March 7th. Busy Phillips has my birthday. Busy Phillips, yeah. You, Busy Phillips, Rikita Reyes are going to have dinner. Oh my God, I would love that dinner.
这太令人兴奋了。我和碧姬·菲利普斯同一天。我们应该办个晚宴。我们应该有一个3月7日……碧姬·菲利普斯和我在同一天生日。碧姬·菲利普斯，是的。你、碧姬·菲利普斯、瑞奇·热维斯要一起吃个晚宴。哦，天哪，我很想去那个晚宴。
And then we'll have dinner with Rachel. That's not a bad idea. Birthday dinner? For a show. Oh. You have a dinner with all the people who share the date and you find the similarities and the differences between them, but they all have the same birthday. Brian, you have a production company. I'm so sorry we're putting you to work again.
然后我们和蕾切尔共进晚餐。这不是个坏主意。生日晚宴？为了一个节目。哦。你和所有在同一天生日的人共进晚餐，然后你发现他们之间的相似之处和不同之处，但他们都有相同的生日。布莱恩，你有一家制作公司。很抱歉我们又让你开始工作了。
This has to stop. Rather than that, let me give it to you and I take 10%. There it is. That's it. And welcome to Hollywood. Thank you so much for coming in today. This was fun, thank you. This was, it was so good to see you again.
这必须停止了。与其那样，不如你交给我，我抽成10%。就是这样。就这样。欢迎来到好莱坞。非常感谢你今天能来。这太有趣了，谢谢你。这真的是，能再次见到你太好了。
You too. You know, this episode, it was beautiful. It turned out great. I just rewatched it and it's so good. Even though we all almost died. It's a great episode and it's a classic and people love it. And they don't know. It is a classic and now when people see us fly across the bus,
你也是。你知道的，这一集，太美妙了。结果很棒。我刚刚重温了一遍，它太棒了。尽管我们差点都死了。这是一集伟大的节目，是一部经典，人们都爱它。他们不知道。它是一部经典，现在当人们看到我们飞过巴士时，
I think we needed that moment. We did. I think we need it. It made the pie that much sweeter. We did use it. I know. It's the actual tape. It's in there.
我想我们需要那个时刻。我们确实需要。我想我们需要它。它让之后的派变得更加甜蜜。我们确实用了它。我知道。那是实际的磁带。就在里面。
Yeah. And now you can relive it in our book. Yes, thank you. Angela, that's so cool. Yeah. Oh, thank you very much. You're welcome buck. Thank you, Angela. That's so cool. Yeah. Oh, thank you very much. You're welcome.
是的。现在你可以在我们的书里重温它了。是的，谢谢你。安吉拉，这太酷了。是的。哦，非常感谢你。不客气，伙计。谢谢你，安吉拉。这太酷了。是的。哦，非常感谢你。不客气。
We love you so much. I'm gonna bring you some dosenberries and we'll all sip some. Do you have it on ice? Do you have it that straight? Yes, I do. How do you have it? You know, any way you like it is the right way.
我们太爱你啦。我要给你带一些Dos Omres，我们大家一起抿几口。你是加冰喝的吗？你是纯饮的吗？是的，我加冰。你平时怎么喝？你知道的，任何你喜欢的方式都是对的方式。
I like it just neat. Maybe. I like it, just neat. Maybe one big ice cube and just let it chill without diluting it and just sip it. It's so great just sipping it. Do you ever mix it? Oh yeah, all the time. It goes in a cocktail as well. So well, in a margarita, in a paloma,
我喜欢纯饮。也许。我喜欢纯饮。也许加一个大冰块，让它变凉而不被稀释，然后小口抿着。这样小口抿着感觉太棒了。你从来不调酒吗？哦，对，一直都调。它也可以放进鸡尾酒里。非常适合，放进玛格丽特里，放进帕洛玛里，
in an old fashioned, in a groany. Oh, you like old fashioned, and a groany. Oh, you like old fashioned, a groany. Oh, yeah. Those are my faves. So good. Yeah. Try a mescal on a groany. Ooh, that sounds good.
放进古典酒里，放进尼格罗尼里。哦，你喜欢古典酒，尼格罗尼。哦，是的。那些是我的最爱。太棒了。是的，试试用梅斯卡尔酒做尼格罗尼。哦，听起来不错。
You're going to love it. Well, there you have it, our interview with Brian Cranston. I could not have enjoyed that more, Angela. He's the best. The best. Yeah. Big thank you to Brian for joining us in the studio being so gracious with his time.
你会喜欢的。好了，这就是我们对布莱恩·克兰斯顿的采访。我不能更享受这个过程了，安吉拉。他是最棒的。最棒的。是的。非常感谢布莱恩加入我们的录音室，并且非常慷慨地抽出他的时间。
And thank you all for listening. We will be back on Monday with a special Monday motivation episode with Kendra Adachi, the lazy genius. We can't wait for you to hear it. And then on Wednesday, it's Here Comes Trouble. So two episodes next week. Two Office Ladies. Two Office Ladies.
谢谢大家的收听。我们将在周一带着一期特殊的周一动力节目回归，嘉宾是“懒惰天才”肯德拉·安达奇。我们等不及让你们听了。然后周三是《麻烦来了》。所以下周有两集节目。两期办公室女士。两期办公室女士。
See you then. See ya. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
到时见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是 Jordan Duffy。我们的副制作人是 Ainsley Bubbicoe。我们的主题曲是 Creed Bratton 创作的《Rubber Tree》。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。